si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi
alors Michel Serrault vous vous êtes
beaucoup moqué au début de votre
carrière avec Jean Poiret des interviews
à la télévision c'est même été le début
de votre carrière donc vous allez payer
ce soir on va faire une interview nulle
en
revanche
[Musique]
Michel Serrault est-ce que vous
préfériez Hitler ou Staline
je les ai pas aimé ni les années parce
que
je préférais Alex et avatars
Michel Serrault vous devez partir 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial oui avec
quelqu'un oui vous préférez partir avec
Fabrice Luchini Edouard Baer ou José
Garcia
je les connais je les connais bien je
les aime beaucoup mais lui j'ai pas je
le connais aussi je vous intéresse
Édouard
m'intéresse il m'intéresse il faut que
je la personnage oui il faut qu'il se
modèle un peu qu'il met il y a je pense
que je peux lui dire encore des choses
les autres ils sont ils savent ce qu'ils
ont à faire peut-être trop mais lui
Berne on peut encore travailler vous
connaissez dans ce blond oui elle est
mignonne
des consommations non c'est à mon avis
c'est des paquets cadeaux pour l'Unicef
ah bon est-ce que vous préféreriez
Michel Serrault faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide très laide
ou un mec très beau
oh je me barre
attention le mot le plus con en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore ou oui oui
non c'est ça va
je t'aime ça va
c'est con je vais le mettre dans mon
questionnaire ah oui s'il vous plaît je
toucherai la bombe atomique arrive dans
5 minutes vous faites quoi enfin et oui
vous faites quoi quoi dans les 5 minutes
qui vous reste à vivre je ne regarde ma
montre je dis j'ai plus de 4 3
avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit Anne Sinclair
Laure Sinclair
ou Bret Sinclair la première Anne
Sinclair
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
c'est mon Briard ah oui
j'adore ce chien il a 3 ans il est beau
comme tout etc
ma femme se rend pas compte parce que
bon ma femme bon je n'aime pas beaucoup
je parle elle trouve que pas trop d'elle
mais elles sont pas très bien compte
parce que mais ça c'est autre chose moi
quand je vois mon chien j'ai
l'impression de voir une personne
et alors il se dresse il est aussi grand
que moi
il a la moustache comme moi non non
ça paraît rigolo comme ça
je dis est-ce que tu veux manger
est-ce que tu crois que il peut devenir
un humain je crois qu'il faut arrêter
les pétards
on est tous les deux
on est bloqué dans un chalet au Tyrol
oui il a beaucoup neigé on peut pas
bouger du chalet on a rien à manger je
meurs de faim vous êtes obligé de me
manger vous commencez par quelle partie
de mon corps
parce que ça me paraît elles sont assez
belles et importantes
puis ça te fera pas mal mal
je vais te manger les oreilles oh
il va se péter un plombage sur
l'oreillette
quelle est à votre avis Michel Serrault
le sport le plus con
celui qu'on fait pas
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi
je sais pas ce qu'ils vont de là dedans
et toi Thierry je retire
de ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu